funeral prayers have been held in Kuwait
for amid shik Naf almed Al saah who died
at the age of 86 on Saturday the burial
ceremony was restricted to close family
shik LF governed for the past three
years 83-year-old Crown Prince shik
Michel almad alabah has been named his
successor the country has entered 40
days of mourning let's bring in our
correspondent Assad B he's live for us
in kuwa city so what happened where you
are earlier
assd
well the funeral took place at the
mosque behind me it was a simple funeral
it was open to the public there was a
considerable security presence here
roads were closed there were metal
detectors uh set up uh but this was also
a mosque that was built from the funds
donated by she Noah almed Al saah and it
was just 50 Metter away from his home
now he was known as The Humble Amir
through his characteristics and
mannerisms and it was seen as a humble
funeral prayer and a humble burial
ceremony attended by close family
members now talk is now about his
successor she Mish Al Ahmed Al Sabah uh
and what happens next and ASA do we
expect any change of policy from the new
amid who was taking power at the same
age that the late amid took
power well not really he was already
taking on considerable responsibilities
since sh noaf had fallen ill uh but what
people are looking towards is who he
will name as his Heir now under the
Constitution from the moment he swears
oath in Parliament he has one year to
name his air now people are looking the
next generation is looking uh to someone
younger possibly and there is this
relationship between uh the parliament
here and the monarchy and sometimes what
happens is we have that to and fro but
we don't expect any major changes in
policy at least domestically and
regionally Kuwait has always been a a a
consiliary member in the in the region
has tried to make friends and foes of
nobody and in fact was instrumental in
end ending the blockade onq that was
imposed by Saudi Arabia Egypt UAE and
Bahrain in fact the picture that was
taken at the signing that signified the
end of that blockade in Saudi Arabia in
ALA the picture was taken there when all
the leaders were lined up it was shik
Noah that was standing next to the Amir
ofq now we don't expect
any major changes in terms of regional
policy but when that new air is
announced that would May signify some
changes but only uh we can only wait and
see what happens next all right ASA
thank you very much for that that's
asset big live in Kuwait City